le sport avec le football une journée de
championnat ce soir est déjà un choc les
deux premiers face à face pour cette
quatrième journée du championnat psg
contre bordeaux c'est au parc des
princes un paris saint germain qui
démarre la saison en trombe
il est même leader du championnat pour
la première fois de son histoire
olivier rey en était à paris c'est le
temps des travaux
le paris saint germain n'a pas échappé à
cette règle en s'offrant un ravalement
de première classe avec huit nouveaux
joueurs michel bibard le défenseur
international de nantes claude lobby un
arrière latéral de mai ce qui promet
beaucoup de laval au marc séné un milieu
de terrain technique robert jack qui
jouait à nancy un attaquant très rapide
fabrice poullain donnons également un
travailleur pour le milieu de terrain
paul vermeulen un pur gaucher
néerlandais est dans les buts
le numéro un français joël bats ajoutez
à cela
l'argentin taf on sait qu'actuellement
blessé en attaque et un nouvel
entraîneur gérard oubli qui après trois
ans passés à lens avec le bonheur que
l'on sait a décidé de tenter
l'expérience parisienne ou plutôt
laventure car nombreux sont les
entraîneurs qui ont échoué à paris qui a
la réputation d'être un club vraiment
pas comme les autres
c'est avec un groupe de 18
professionnels et un stagiaire couilles
espère bâtir ce nouveau paris saint
germain
jusqu'à présent rien n'est venu gripper
le travail de gérard ou des anciens et
nouveaux joueurs ont compris le message
lancé par leur nouvel entraîneur
un message qui est plutôt ambitieux
exploiter au maximum les possibilités
des joueurs harmoniser le tout
favoriser leur expression
l'entraîneur c'est celui qui en quelque
sorte quelque fois réduit un petit peu
les incertitudes qui peut exister au
niveau du joueur c'est celui qui donne
la confiance
qui rassure et qui bien sûr détermine un
petit peu l'orientation et
l'organisation au sein de l'équipe de
france au sein du club
une grande équipe donc pour le psg cette
année une grande équipe dans la capitale
pourvu que ça dure notre invité fait
francis borelli président du psg qui est
très en forme aussi en début de saison
il faut le dire alors le nouveau look de
psg c'est surtout des joueurs qui ont
changé d âge nouveaux joueurs qui ont
été achetés comme bat par exemple où ça
va bien au delà la coûtait chaque année
j'essaie de faire au mieux et est ce que
c'est la bonne année
chaque fois on prétend que ça devrait
l'être le répond je crois que ce soir
c'est un test important contre le
champion
clayeux une équipe solide maintenant
mais je dois dire la vérité je le dis
chaque année on le dit pour moi même et
pour cette année fectivement il ya un
mieux ne pas accentuer alors on espère
donc ce soit vrai c'est à dire que le
paris saint germain est rentrés dans
l'ère de la sagesse vous profiter
aujourd'hui du fruit de l'expérience
vous êtes assagi parce que les époques
ou peut-être le recrutement n'était pas
tout à fait ce que l'on aurait pu
attendre un peu exagéré ou pas tout à
fait à la hauteur
oui je le sais ce de dire chars ont fait
l'amitié de m'inviter dire qu'il
faudrait tordre définitivement le cou à
cette légende qui est fausse d'où ces
légendes c'est difficile à les faire
revenir
je crois que si on cale au palmarès du
parisien en toute humilité en toute
simplicité vrai que 80 ans parce que ma
présidence on n'est pas si fantasque que
ça mais décidément il a dit que paris
dans tous les commentaires ce serait
toujours suivi une bande à part un club
à part
alors les seuls qui peut cibler ce
côté-là continuer à être avec cependant
finalité de bons résultats et ça veut
dire laisser aller leur ciel et adam
borelli à cette fois-ci l'impression que
enfin les espoirs correspondent aux
moyens qu'il a mis en action
oui c'est exact c'est là que j'ai le
sentiment très doux que il est si à
mieux devait se faire jour on
comprendrait les raisons parce que cette
année j'ai exigé des non sans mal mais
j'ai opté satisfaction que je sois fait
que vous le désirez réellement mais
cette élection je crois de budget
d'économies
on a expliqué ici mais je voudrais pas
je voulais cracher sur le passé et puis
qu'il y ait le passé on a une belle
journée de bons résultats c'est pas mal
alors vous parler un petit peu de budget
va pas y revenir effectivement mais pour
psg il faut forcément un gros budget il
faut forcément pour parer une équipe
grandiose la mesure à hauteur de ce
qu'on présente la capitale sur la tâche
de je crois d'intérêt de noblesse
paris n'est et paris heureux ça implique
cinq jours donne néanmoins plus
particulièrement de faire les efforts
nécessaires pour être sûrs d'être à la
hauteur de ce qu'on appelle presque
cavalièrement les ambitions de paris
mais nous sommes confrontés à des
embûches naturel encore une fois l'ong
équipe était ici mais entre choix ce
n'est pas pour nous déplaire pas plus à
moi que ceux qui sont autour de moi et
qui m'encourage aussi bien mon sponsor
que les mairies et le public ce public
qui lui vaut un petit peu boudé très
justement n'ont passé et dont c'est
hallucinant de l'euro pour guérir
justement avec un grand slogan qui paie
qui regroupe un peu toute cette ambition
satisfait ou remboursé
ce soir c'est le grand choc s'ils jouent
mal bon en bourse et non c'est pas ce
niveau là on n'est pas aussi fou de
prendre parce que d'abord j'espère qu'il
sera sadc porte un bon résultat et un
bon spectacle car je viens de voir votre
actualité
elle est présente
la première forme je suis avec loca
seriez quand il a parlé de football veut
pas jouer au marchand bonheur mais tout
de même c'est la fête c'est la joie et
le paraguay s'est modestement de
contribuer à cette joie la cites antec
la joie soit au rendez vous ce soir
alors jetez vous à l'eau un pronostic
pour ce soir plus tu es j'ai toujours
dit c'est le seul moment je ne suis rien
une modeste je joue toujours pour gagner
quand je perde a fait contre mauvaise
fortune bon coeur moi départ je suis
toujours comme ça tu as mon état d'âme
d'une plaque une victoire du ps de ce
soir je vois pas comment ça se compte
remercie président borelli